so sketch the graph of this parabola
showing all important features tada
there it is now just a quick note for
you right you have to think carefully
when you're starting to graph things now
because as you look at this you see all
of those parts you're like oh I have to
do lots of stuff with this graph
afterwards right so you cannot make this
like a sometimes I talk about the fact
that draw a quick and dirty graph just
so you can see what's going on right but
this is not a quick and dirty graph this
is a graph that you can see from the
question they want us to do lots of
things with okay so you have to do this
one quite carefully in most cases it
doesn't really matter if you're
horizontal and vertical scales are
inconsistent but in this case when you
are graphing the inverse on the same
graph it causes you a lot of problems if
your scale is off so it's in your
interest it's a simple shape so invest
in it a little bit to make it accurate
you can see I've got my vertex my
intercepts or there that's my parabola
that's part one okay
part two find the largest domain
containing x equals zero for which the
inverse function exists so you can see
I've highlighted this in blue over here
this has a stationary point in it so I
know I have to restrict the domain in
some way I can only pick one half or the
other in order to get an inverse
function out of this so why have I chose
on the left hand side rather in the
right head Zone left inside have a look
there's something in the question see
yeah no look look at the question the
question doesn't give you that much
information what does it tell you this
is part to find the largest domain yeah
thank you donate so containing x equals
zero here's x equals zero and here so I
need this part of the graph which means
you must have this left-hand part okay
if you use the right-hand part you're
going to you know you're going to have
an inverse relation it won't work you've
got a double up okay so we've got that
state the domain and range of the
inverse function let me show you how I
did it by far the easiest way was to
work out the domain and range of your
original function right and then for the
domain and range of your inverses you
swap everything around okay so you had
just worked out the original domain so
that will become your
or range where am I put down here yep
but you haven't worked out range yet so
you can see here's my vertex down here
the range of the original parabola is y
is greater than or equal to negative 4
so therefore when you go to your domain
for your inverse its X is greater than
negative 4 so it's just a straight swap
okay now then you have 2 amiss if we
tried we tried but our graphs really
struggle on this it was just a simple
problem but you had to get them looking
right at the same time so what does the
graph look like on the same set of axes
you needed to read ahead in the question
to know you were going to do that in
order to have sort of the right amount
of the corner axes there some of you
kind of tried to extend your set of axes
a little bit but it ended up going a bit
pear-shaped so you can see if you turn
your head turn your head 45 degrees can
you do it can you see if you look along
or draw it in there for you if you look
along this here right you can see the
access to citrate in fact sorry why am I
asking you to turn your head I can do
better than that here we go OOP tada
there's 45 degrees so can you see can
you see here's the symmetry matching up
to this shape which is the part that we
restricted to okay so you obviously can
just turn your page to do that but
that's how you will know you've got your
shape basically right it's quite hard to
see if your axes are not equal to each
other if you're if your scales are not
equal to each other so when you're
dealing with inverses just be careful
it's really helpful to have a consistent
scale okay and then lastly you had to
find the equation of the inverse so here
it is now how did you go about doing it
I wonder this this seemed like the most
straightforward way to me sir I wanted
to complete the square some of you did
this marvelously like it was textbook
thumbs up okay I think Kyser memory is
really good good job right you can see
when you get to this point here you've
completed the square but you try to make
why the subject aren't you so you take
the square root of both sides but
there's a + - why is there a + - in my
working here
think about what the answer remains but
what shape is this from it's from a
parabola it had two parts to it right
the plus and the minus referred to
there's a plus there's an upper half and
there's a minus a lower half just like
if you're doing a semicircle there's a
top semicircle bottom semicircle okay
the best answers said well actually I
only want one of them and there's a
reason why because in an earlier part of
the question I stated the domain
restriction right so you want the part
it's underneath one so that's why you
have to take the negative case okay all
right now um there was a lot in Part B
does anyone any questions about that one
Part B just crying that's okay
all right let's have a look let's move
on to um I'm gonna skip over C and D cos
I thought they were done overall pretty
well the small number of you if you had
issues with it you can come and ask mrs.
Leeds and I have two words I want to go
straight on to aim now some of you a
small number if you panicked ran a time
you're like oh it's this find value I
have a calculator and you've reached for
your calculator and your calculator can
do this for you right of course if you
just calculate up have a look at the
question what's it worth it's worth two
so you'll get one like that's better
than nothing if the bells about to go
but how do you actually get the full
marks for this okay let's have a look at
the way I set this out I'm just going to
put this right off the back for two
marks this is more than what you need
for two marks I'll point to the exact
bits that are important but I've put all
this here so you understand the thought
process underneath what's going on if I
were doing in this this in exam probably
everything from above here I would be
doing in my head okay but if you can't
do it in your head this is what it
should look like right you've got a sine
inverse of negative 4 & 5 that's an
angle of some kind and you have a closed
inverse of 8 on 17 that's another angle
some kind so in order to make the latter
parts of this easier I've just given
them names Theta Phi Alpha Beta wherever
you want okay now first thing to know
there are restrictions on what theatre
can be and fire can be whatever these
angles are based on the inverse trig
functions that are being used
so do you notice here I immediately
without even thinking I look and I say
Oh sine inverse there's a restriction on
that it can only possibly be between
negative plan to and plan to does that
make sense so I know that right at the
gate before I even start drawing any
triangles in the same way cause inverse
has a restriction on it but it's a
different one
remember that think back to your
industry graphs gets armed it's this one
it goes like that and it lands on the
x-axis so it goes from naught to PI so
there's a restriction on this angle as
well now I say negative 4 5 8 on 17
these are sides in right angle triangles
now a significant number of you it's
quite common we'll draw a triangle
whoops sorry
we'll draw a triangle like this thena
when I just say 4 5 3 okay now there's
nothing wrong with drawing a triangle
like this you can still get the answer
out of it okay but I want you to have a
look at this purple triangle and tell
you tell me what information is there in
my diagram the one I've drawn versus
this purple one that is lost when you
just draw a triangle like this it's the
negative and that turns out that turns
out to be kind of really important right
it's tricky with a question like this
because if you tried the positive value
it looks like you get a sensible answer
down the bottom you know like I don't
know what tan inverse of blahblahblah is
you know it seems okay to me
but you have to be careful so I would
encourage you to draw this within the
context of the quadrants write negative
planet una planta means you're in
quadrant four quadrant one this guy I
over here could be quadrant one quadrant
two but then you can say or wait but
sine is negative so that's the fourth
quadrant not the first oh wait cause is
positive that can't be the second
quadrant it must be the first does that
make sense
so from there you then can infer your
values for ten of each of those angles
by reading off the triangles this guy is
a fourth quadrant angle tan is negative
in the fourth quadrant this fires in the
first quadrant so everything's positive
that's why I have 15 on a not maybe if
you're staying on it okay all right um
question
yep okay so good question cuz ASTC can
be positive in quadrant one and in
quadrant four but the piece of
information I know that tells me I can't
be in quadrant four is because cos
inverse doesn't reach quadrant four
right so it comes in before I think
about the a on 17 it comes from this guy
because think about what cos inverse
looks like there it is right so that's
PI on to there right so this is quadrant
one from naught to PI on two and then
this is quadrant two from PI on to 2 pi
but then cos inverse doesn't exist
anywhere else cause sorry quadrant four
would be down here right negative power
2 to zero that would be quadrant 4 which
of course sine inverse can go into
because we know its shape is different
it looks like this right group like so
okay so here is quadrant 1 RP r and here
is quadrant 4 down here negative PI into
two zero zero to a onto that okay it's
quite tricky it's especially weird when
you see me shading you're like what do
you mean that's a quadrant that does
look like a quadrant we're thing about
the angles that correspond to that ok ok
I will skip over F and G because I think
they were okay I mean they're quiet
they're quite brief questions you can
have a look at my answer if you like I
will just point out it's way easier to
differentiate if you use your log laws
first we've seen as many times right if
you have to differentiate or integrate
please simplify first you can do this
with a chain rule and get your answer
out I mean you have to use chain rule
anyway you can use chain rule twice if
you want but it's just less error-prone
if you use it just once okay last one
here is the final question huzzah
okay part one they give you this weird
awkward thing they say differentiate
right part two they then say hey find an
area which means integrate so this is
one of those differentiate hence
integrate questions the derivative turns
out all how conveniently simple tan
inverse of X which of course is what
you have to integrate in the very next
part okay
so there's what I'm going to come up
with cause I'm just reversing the
process I had in part one and then you
just have to be careful and judicious in
your substitution of boundaries into
this common errors
you know log of zero log of one rather
that's zero okay so that's why this all
just comes out in the wash
a few people left it as half log four I
don't think many but some people left it
we know logged laws for this that's some
log of the square root of four so you
can super fie that and there is your
area and in this case Declan would be
right at putting you in it's great here
because they were asking for an area
okay